JFK's assassination the moon landing
area 51
none of these conspiracies have anything
on
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that swears it won't subject
you to a bunch of fish puns in this
episode I mean we ride to do that it
would be a turtle disaster oh sorry I
didn't do that in porpoise ah oh I just
need to clam down sure I can't I can't
keep floundering something called a
sturgeon okay no more it's out of my
system no more fish puns ever I mean
it's not like anyone's ever gonna want a
film theory on Shark Tale anyway ah
Finding Nemo
everybody loves Finding Nemo and why
shouldn't they it's got everything you
could want in an animated children's
film that happens to be about neglected
son's kidnapping imprisonment mental
illness and the dangers of the outside
world remember about the ocean that's my
boy but no seriousness that's the beauty
of Pixar sure Finding Nemo has cute
animated fish talking and making jokes
up beneath the surface there's some
serious adult themes and what if I were
to tell you that there's a Pixar secret
so hidden so subversive and so shocking
that no one has yet to pick up on it
would you believe me let's take it a
step further what if I were to tell you
that one fish Dory
has been lying to us the whole time oh I
am on to you Ellen DeGeneres finding
dory more like exposing dory the truth
is coming out throughout Finding Nemo
small fish against all odds outsmart
bigger predators Nemo was constantly
told that he simply isn't strong enough
to swim in the ocean you know you can't
swim we'll get in the end it's Nemo's
ability to swim that saves him from
being caught by the humans Marlin a
small clownfish no one takes seriously
becomes a legend amongst aquatic life
after surviving encounters with sharks
jellyfish and whales it's such an
important theme to this movie that it
even appears in the closing credits the
tiniest most nervous fish of them all
blenny turns the tables on the sharp
banged angler fish devouring him in one
swift bites the film boils down to one
central idea don't judge people or in
this case fish on appearance alone and
if there's one fish that stands out from
the pack the most vulnerable of all its
Dory at first glance it's easy to
dismiss her
she suffers from short-term memory loss
and as such she has no concept of where
she is at any given point
she just wanders around haphazardly from
place to place sort of like the animated
fish version of mr. bean just keep
swimming just keep swimming swimming
swimming Dory is constantly making silly
and dangerous decisions whether it's
approaching sharks for directions
pretending to know whale talk by slowing
down her speech bouncing up and down on
a jellyfish like a trampoline Dory even
thinks that naval mines are balloon who
would ever take this fish seriously yet
the results tell a completely different
story if you look just at what Dory
accomplishes she's actually the most
competent and knowledgeable fish in the
film Dory successfully barters with the
sharks controlling them via a vegetarian
support group you may not know what
naval mines are but she sure knows how
to shoot a missile out of a downed
submarine she's the only fish that can
read English and the only fish that
speaks whale because yeah slowing down
her speech was actually the correct way
to do it she's the fish that knows today
when she sees the seagull and most
importantly of all the fish that
actually finds Nemo and reunites and
with his father so how do you reconcile
Dory's naive personality with her shrewd
resume the answer lies far in the past
ancient Rome in fact no I don't hear me
out that sounds weird but hear me out
Claudius was the Roman Emperor from 41
to 54 AD as a child he was afflicted
with a limp and slight deafness as such
she was ostracized by his wealthy family
and considered a disgrace to the name
basically he was Tyrion Lannister these
handicaps though saved Claudius during
the tumultuous rule of Tiberius and
Caligula who killed all noblemen and
potential heirs to the throne
Claudius though was spared because he
wasn't perceived as a threat and despite
Claudius's physical limitations he was
an expert political thinker just like
Tyrion Lannister after Caligula was
assassinated Claudius became the Emperor
and under his rule Rome returned to the
prosperity of Augustus reign aqueducts
new roads canals they were all built and
the Empire was once again connected so
what does any of this have to do with a
fictional animated fish well just like
Claudia story is using a physical
limitation to ward off potential threats
except unlike Claudius she actually
doesn't have those physical limitations
you heard me right I'm saying right here
and right now
Dory doesn't
suffer from short-term memory loss in
the entirety of finding nemo she's
faking it
don't let that wide-eyed freckled face
fool you by playing our knowledge of the
normal symptoms for short-term memory
loss - dory we can find cracks in her
so-called story it's time that dory flop
like a fish there are actually two main
forms of amnesia retrograde and
anterograde in retrograde amnesia a
person forgets everything that's
happened before an injury or accident
someone suffering from retrograde
amnesia can still form new memories
however memories created prior to the
injury are lost this is typically caused
by head trauma to the brain in
particular the hippocampus which encodes
new memories think of retrograde as the
born identity of amnesia after Jason
Bourne is shot and left for dead he has
no recollection of who he is or what
happened people suffering from
retrograde amnesia can recall general
knowledge but not specifics so in the
case of Jason Bourne he can still
remember how to kill a man with a hand
towel but he can't remember the name of
the man who taught him how to kill a man
with a hand towel the second type of
amnesia and tarot grade is commonly
referred to as short-term memory loss
and this is the form of amnesia that
Dory's supposedly suffers from in
anterograde amnesia a person is unable
to create new memories following a
traumatic event long-term memories
before that event however remain intact
a person with anterograde amnesia may be
able to remember their high school
mascot but they'll be unable to tell you
what they just had for lunch 20 minutes
ago
think of anterograde as the memento of
amnesia you know the indie lessor scene
version of retrogrades more common
blockbuster in anterograde amnesia
people lose declarative memory the
recollection of facts but they retain
non-declarative memory otherwise known
as their procedural memory probably the
best way to explain this difference to
you is to take you through the most
famous documented case of anterograde
amnesia ever recorded a patient simply
known by the code name hm in 1953 Henry
Gustav Malaya s'en had a lobectomy to
cure his epilepsy basically he had a big
chunk of his brain removed
unfortunately the procedure while
successfully curing the epilepsy
resulted in anterograde amnesia leaving
Henry unable to form new memories /
Records Henry loved to do crossword
puzzles he could fill in all the answers
pertaining to events before his surgery
struggled with any answers that related
to events happening afterwards and yet
despite the setback Henry was still able
to retain information through procedural
memory scientists would give Henry the
same maze to complete every day and when
he was asked whether he remembered doing
the maze before he had no memory of ever
seeing it in his life and yet he could
instinctually remember how to finish the
maze in a reduced amount of time each
trial he was getting faster at the maze
without ever realizing that he had done
the maze in the past Dory on the surface
shows many of the same symptoms
associated with anterograde amnesia when
she leads Marlin to the boat that took
Nemo she keeps forgetting who he is
stop following me okay person's name
would fall under declarative memory so
it makes sense that Dory keeps
forgetting Marlin in fact Dory
consistently has trouble with names
calling Nemo fabio chico bingo Harpo and
Elmo but never his actual name Dory also
struggles to remember events that have
just occurred while they're being chased
by sharks midway through their escape
she forgets that she's being chased at
all when Dory and Marlin lose the scuba
mask or he can't remember what they lost
all these instances are consistent with
short-term memory loss just like patient
HM that being said Dory does show a
strange knack for remembering particular
phrases especially our personal motto
just keep swimming just keep swimming
later Dory can even remember the address
Nemo's being kept at a Sherman 42
Wallaby Way Sydney those would also
classify as declarative memories so is
that the proof I'm talking about of her
faking well actually no according to
Scientific American one of the most
common suggestions for better short-term
memory is to use mnemonic devices
Dory's mantra of always keeps swimming
fits as a simple mnemonic device
reminding her of her primary survival
tactic through simple repeated phrases
people suffering from short-term memory
loss can actually start to learn and to
remember and as for that address
Dory's repetition of the numbers is
consistent with procedural memory but
then how can Dory read English words
like she does with the exit sign and the
scuba mask without having any knowledge
of that ability by this logic shouldn't
Dory be unable to read as well shouldn't
she have forgotten how to well no
believe it or not there are actually
multiple instances of anterograde
amnesia acts learning to play an
instrument in these
cases the amnesiac has no recollection
of learning the instrumental and asked
to play they can do so extremely well
this is because instruments are learned
through repeated practice procedural
memory
think of how HM can't remember finishing
the maze every day but when they ask him
to do it again he can complete it much
quicker than the day before thus there's
a scientific precedent for Dory being
able to read while still not remembering
that she can in the first place
you can read every single one of Dory's
accomplishments can be attributed to
procedural memory she knows how to speak
whale avoid seagulls read all because
she's done so before Dory wouldn't
remember that she has these abilities
but instinctually she would still know
how to do them so then what am i doing
calling Dory a liar Who am I kidding I
just spent an entire episode arguing
against myself maybe Dory does suffer
from anterograde amnesia everything
seems to check out I guess sometimes the
children's film about talking animated
fish is simply just a children's film
about talking animated fish story you're
free to swim away
hi I suffer from short-term memory loss
how could dory remember the boats but
then forget meeting Marlin the boat
wouldn't fall under procedural memory
dory seeing a boat would be a fact a
declarative memory and if Dory truly has
anterograde amnesia
like all declarative memories she should
have forgotten it just like she forgets
Marlins name over and over again it
doesn't add up the only way for this to
make sense is that Dory has been faking
it the whole time looks like I was right
all along and I've got even more proof
next time but in the meantime remember
that's just a theory a film theory and
cuts just keep subscribing just keep
subscribing just keep subscribing to
make sure you're notified next week of
part 2 of this video coming out trust me
we found a ton of evidence that exposes
Dory for the liar that she is and please
while you're waiting click here to check
out my friends over at the wisecrack
channel if you enjoyed this video then
you're gonna love their video about The
Incredibles exposing the less than
stellar message that that movie has to
teach all the viewers watching it it's a
pretty mind-blowing theory they have
over there so click here check it out
and finally I have the results from last
week's theory about the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles in an overwhelming
majority twice the amount of any other
turtle your favorite Teenage Mutant
Ninja to wielding Terrapin was Leonardo
he had about 40,000 votes everyone else
was hanging around 20k very interesting
I was very very surprised to see that I
didn't expect it yay Leo congratulations
big winner now if you'll excuse me I've
gotta pick up the pieces of that broken
coffee cup foot hazard my friends I
don't want us be stepping on that a week
from now injure my foot geez see you
next week